after president Trump's devastating
political the heat over Trump care and
is now not to return to health care in
its wake Trump allies say that he will
move next on tax reform that was an open
question actually since Trump has also
talked in sterling terms about a huge
infrastructure bill that would some
petroleum bucks in a public works but
given the Trump care political circular
firing squad well tax reform be any
easier for Trump to ram through Congress
here are five things you need to know
first deficit matters one of the first
prominent Republican talking points
during the Obama era was that Obama had
blown out the deficit which of course he
had the national debt was ten point six
trillion when Obama took office it was
almost twenty trillion run Obama left
office tax reform lowering the tax rate
will increase the deficit in the short
term even if the supply-side logic that
economic growth will increase tax
revenues pays off in the long term that
means Republicans are going to have to
contend with the school of headlines
that they're blowing out spending even
if they're just letting people keep
their own money and that's if they don't
use Budget Reconciliation if they do use
that the process known as Budget
Reconciliation they'll have to
demonstrate that their plan won't
increase the deficit over the next ten
years to only need fifty one votes and
the projected savings from Trump care
one trillion bucks over 10 years
supposedly won't be available as an
excuse to cut taxes since Trump care
didn't pass and since that estimate
wasn't actually true tax reform advocate
Grover Norquist says Trump cares failure
will only allow the top marginal tax
rate to drop the twenty-eight percent
rather than twenty percent on this basis
second Trump has sent mixed messages on
taxes during the campaign Trump's tax
plan was one of the best among all
Republican candidates he called for
dramatic to lowering of all of the top
tax brackets but in 2011 Trump said
quote I don't mind sacrificing for the
country to be honest with you before he
rolled out his campaign plan he talked
openly about raising taxes on the
highest income earners he said I would
let people without making hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year pace and tax
I don't mind paying a little more in
taxes in may 2016 he dumped on his own
tax plan after it came out he told CNBC
he wasn't a fan of tax breaks for high
earners he said quote I am so much more
into the middle class who have just been
absolutely forgotten in our country he
said that his original tax plan was
merely a negotiation starting point
Trump said of tax rates for the highest
earners on my plan they're going down
but by the time it's negotiated they
will go up never mind
twenty percent of income earners pay
eighty four percent of all federal
income taxes and nearly all of the net
federal income tax third Trump loves
carrots so Trump thinks trade is a
zero-sum game a mercantilist position
that has been debunked repeatedly by
economists but that means he thinks that
American companies can only benefit if
we tacked imports and subsidized exports
Trump's plain and simple tariff plan has
now been turned into something slightly
more acceptable by the Republican
Congress the border adjustment tax which
is essentially a value-added tax all
Europe investment returns are interrupt
but all goods sold in the US are taxed
at twenty percent including investment
goods while the corporate were tax is
lowered that means a subsidy for
exporting companies and a penalty for
importers even importers who buy
products to use in exports this should
raise the value of the dollar and buy an
equivalent amount of the tax it also
punishes importers but as William Gale
of the Brookings Institution explains
quote if the theory is correct and the
exchange rate fully adjust rises by the
level of the text the border adjustment
would have no effect on the trade
balance the level exports level imports
the domestic price level or the net
profitability of importers and exporters
Trump may embrace the border adjustment
act as a substitute for his tariff love
particularly since he doesn't seem to
understand the intricacies of the border
adjustment act but what happened when
free traders in Congress object saying
that importing American companies like
Walmart shouldn't be penalized or what
happens when the World Trade
Organization says the border adjustment
tax breaks its rules and Trump tries to
ram it through anyway calling those who
opposed him globalist for Trump has very
little leverage with Republicans at this
point from threatened Republicans to
pass don't care instead he had to pull
his bill because it appeared he'd be
short by up to 40 votes in the house
Trump's desire to rush the bill is
obvious lack of knowledge on the bill
his mixed messaging on its contents all
of it combined to undercut his leverage
his leverage isn't going to grow on tax
reform particularly given all the
interest involved finally Democrats are
not going to work with Trump Trump seems
to think that if Republicans won't work
with him Democrats will that's silly
Democrats despise Trump they think he's
weak they won't be able to answer to a
base with a below ten percent approval
rating for the president so it's tax
reform going to go better than health
care reform would be hard for it to go
worse some sort of deal is more likely
to be hammered out for sure but it won't
be Trump just cutting the Gordian knot
it will be a naughty complex sickened
the biggest question right now is
whether Trump has the patience to
actually push something through i'm ben
shapiro this is the venture
yup
Wow when last we left our sada it was
totally unclear as to whether the bill
would pass whether in fact the
Republicans would be able to pass a
trump care the answer it turns out was
no and we're gonna get to all the
ramifications of that including most
importantly as Yoda suggests the Shroud
of the dark side has fallen begun the
club except now it's the one Republicans
that the war on conservatives
particularly not the one Republicans the
war on conservatives has begun and we'll
talk all about that because Trump is
actually leading that wore this is what
some of us had feared but we'll get to
that in just a second first we have to
say thank you to our advertisers over at
Mac weldon so whatever underwear
whatever sweatpants whatever tee shirt
you're wearing right now it is not as
good as what you'd be wearing if you are
wearing Mac Walden I am personally
learning math well in underwear right
now they are the finest underwear I have
ever owned I have thrown out all of my
other underwear it is twenty percent off
your first order when you go to map
weldon calm right now and use promo code
Shapiro not only does the product really
hold up me send it through the wash a
bunch of times and it just feels the
same way that it did the first time they
used it not only that they also have a
line of silver underwear and shirts that
are antimicrobial so it gets rid of the
stench which is fantastic they want you
to be comfortable so if you if you get
your first pair and you don't like it
you can still keep it and they will
refund you no questions asked they
perform really well too it's great for
working out it's good for going out it's
all good looking gear super comfortable
it's good for relaxing in you know I
dress just to the nines on this show but
when I go home I don't wear this I get
immediately into my math wells in gear
and spend the rest of the day writing
well in the most comfortable clothing I
can find and that is mack wells and go
to Mack Weldon calm get twenty percent
off using that promo code Shapiro that
is mack wells and ma ck weldon wel do n
calm and get twenty percent off use that
promo code shapiro is a pretty solid
deal and again best underwear i have
ever owned and the rest of their gear is
awesome as well ok so again when last we
left our story it was not clear who
thursday so we had to leave before the
apex of the story before the climax of
the story and the story climax with
Trump care going down to flaming defeat
and it went down flaming to feed because
of the crappy bill it has to be frank
about this there's a lot of blame to go
around the people who are not to blame
the only people who are not to blame in
this whole situation are the people who
took seriously the promises that they
made to the American people over and
over and over again for seven years that
they were going to repeal Obamacare not
replace it with Obamacare lights not
replace it with Obamacare part 2 point 0
not replace it with a new subsidy not
replace it with a new entitlement
program not replace it with the same
central regulations that Obamacare
maintained no no no the people who are
honest that people who are not to blame
here are the people who are not lying to
you namely the people in the house
freedom caucus so who's getting blamed
any guesses that's right the house
freedom caucus of course because if you
have the gall to cross Donald Trump that
means that you must pay the price now it
is worthwhile noting it was not just the
house freedom caucus that opposed this
bill apparently the reason that it was
pulled as it wasn't even close so
Republicans right now look a 40-seat
majority in the house they could have
lost 22 votes on this thing and still
been able to pass it they didn't they
were losing something close to 50 or 60
votes on this thing not only the freedom
caucus a lot of moderates didn't like it
the moderates didn't like it because the
CBO score on this thing thought it was
wildly unpopular seventeen percent of
Americans were approving of Trump care
okay that was much less popular than
Obama care even when Obamacare passed
and that was an unpopular piece of
legislation when Obamacare passed it was
at forty percent in the approval ratings
Trump care was at seventeen percent in
the approval ratings so it's political
suicide for a lot of these members to
vote for this crappy bill and so it went
down and naturally the moderates weren't
blamed Paul Ryan wasn't really blamed
except by you know people like me Donald
Trump wasn't played because Donald Trump
can never be blamed for anything because
we have so much stake in him that we
must we must greenlight anything he ever
does every excuse must be made for him
the the radically shifting logic about
Donald Trump in order to make excuses
for the fact that he did a pretty
terrible job pushing this bill is it's
pretty it's pretty amazing I want to go
through each player in this drama and
explain what they did right and what
they did wrong and who deserves the
blame but right now all fire is focused
on the Conservatives and Donald Trump
and his team are openly saying that they
now want to pander to Democrats they
will have to turn to the left and we'll
get to that in just a little while but
first first what did Trump do wrong so
here's what Trump did wrong Trump had no
ass on this what I mean by that is that
Trump did not have the patience to sit
for 13 months and hash out a deal the
way Obama did with Obamacare Obama was a
terrible president he was but the man at
least had asked enough to sit around for
13 months and hash out a deal with his
own people for 13 months 13 months
Donald Trump gave the sucker about 13
days hey it really was like 17 days from
inception to failure and that was after
seven years of planning why was that
well the reason was because Trump
signaled to Ryan he didn't have the ass
to do this for 17 months or 13 months or
13 minutes he signaled to Ryan you
better give me what I want we better get
this thing through fast I don't want to
spend political capital on this I don't
want to be going into the midterm
elections talking about this I don't
want to be going into reelection talking
about this and I don't want to pay the
political price for repealing Obamacare
if it means that my promises that I
should never have made about health
insurance aren't able to come true so
Ryan immediately went to the drawing
board he negotiated with himself right
he didn't go and put together National
Coalition you have time for that I mean
it and he didn't have time to coordinate
with McConnell or at the house freedom
caucus Trump didn't bother to actually
have these people over for dinner and
try and talk with them until the last
five minutes before the bill was rammed
through even when it was rammed through
he then deployed the absolute rhetorical
blunderbuss of Steve benen to walk into
the room with the house freedom caucus
and yell at them which is Steve's
preferred mode of communication also
doesn't hurt Steven any way to do that
obviously because he gets to show Donald
Trump what a loyal guy he is and if the
thing goes down guess who gets blamed
Brian's previous which is what he likes
anyway in any case Trump didn't care
about this issue try made a bunch of
false promises about this particular
issue you can't have repeal of Obamacare
without a death spiral without you can't
repeal the individual mandate without a
death spiral almost are willing to
relieve the central regulations in
Obamacare Trump was not willing to do
that and so Trump tried to ram through a
bill that was bad and then he disowned
the thing Tom cotton got that's pretty
much right to senator from Arkansas he
said look you cannot release a plan in
18 days and hope that this thing is
going to go through biggest broken pump
promise in political history what's your
reaction to that judgment well John
first to say the president is right that
the Democrats Davis Obamacare and the
failure of this bill this week doesn't
solve the problems of Obamacare it's
continuing to get worse and our help
groaning under the weight of Obamacare
so we're have to revisit it we now have
the time to do it in a more deliberate
and careful fashion but ultimately I
don't think you can lay the defeat of
this bill last week on any single
faction in the House of Representatives
some conservatives opposed it some
moderate supposed it even chairman of
powerful committees opposed it I think
the problem was with first the bill and
in the process health care is very
complicated issue to release a bill that
was written in secret and then expect to
pass it in 18 days I just don't think
was feasible so the reason that it had
to be passed in 18 days is because of
Trump because Trump wanted it now he
wanted what he wanted now and he wasn't
going to take no for an answer and so
Ryan had two choices he could either go
and do all the hard flogging and ignore
Trump and then present Trump with a bill
after he did all the hard flogging with
front pushing against him the entire
time or he could try and do Trump's
bidding and become his Lackey on this
thing and then the thing presumably
would pass because the idea here was
that Ryan would lock down the
establishment Trump would lock down the
freedom caucus and together they would
be able to ram this thing through that
didn't happen because the bill itself
was garbage and now I don't believe what
Mick Mulvaney did the office of
management budget what he had to say he
said all the other problem here is that
Trump just didn't think that DC was this
broken so the President himself pins
this on the freedom caucus Club for
Growth Heritage Foundation so
essentially conservative interest groups
and the most conservative caucus on the
house the caucus you were a member of
just six months again I think there's
probably plenty of blame to go around as
we SAT over the last two days and try to
figure out what happened I think what
happened is that Washington one I think
one thing we learned this week is that
Washington was a lot more broken than
president Trump thought that it was what
you have a right there this is nonsense
president Trump around on the promise
the Washington DC was broken and he
could fix it immediately he doesn't have
the patience to actually fix it it's not
an easy process it's not something where
you can come in and just use your big
businessman skills and cut the Gordian
knot that's not how this works so that's
the blame that Trump bears is really a
character flaw with him which is that he
has a lack of attention he didn't care
about these issues to begin with he
didn't have the ass to sit there for 13
months and actually just put together a
bill that would work now the other
person who's to blame here mostly is
paul ryan paul ryan absolutely is to
blame here paul ryan is the one who
decided to go along with trump's
shortened timeline his stupid timeline
it was a dumb timeline he's the one who
cited that instead of going and
negotiating with all the various parties
I mean Paul Ryan's been there for a
while he could have spent the past few
months going to all the available
parties and talking with them about what
can pass in what can't going to the
freedom caucus and saying what can pass
in what can't instead he didn't he
waited for Trump to become president and
then he tried to rush this thing through
in about five minutes that is Paul
Ryan's fault it is his job to cobble
together a bill that people can actually
vote for instead he cobbled together the
single most unpopular bill I have ever
seen proposed in front of the house
republicans by house republicans it's
astonishing I mean do you understand how
crazy it is I mean John Boehner did this
a couple of times we understand how
crazy it is the Paul Ryan who is
supposed to be the consensus guy guy who
had to be begged into being Speaker of
the House couldn't put together a bill
better than this so naturally this
alleged some controversy everybody has
sort of been expecting Trump to jump
Paul Ryan under the bus because Ryan is
allied with wines previous in the White
House and steve van and doesn't like
Ryan's previous or Paul Ryan and so
there's been a lot of Machiavellian
manipulations here so over the weekend
Donald Trump tweeted that he wanted
everybody to watch judge Jeanine Pirro
and people didn't know what he was
talking about there was one theory that
was plausible that suggested that he was
talking about judge jeanine het was
supposed to reveal something about the
leaks investigation or something and but
but Trump saw that because there was
like a little kai run on Fox the other
theory is that he told people to watch
judge jeanine because he knew judge
Jeanine was going to lead off with this
ran so here's judge jeanine Paul Ryan
needs to step down as Speaker of the
House the reason he failed to deliver
the votes on his health care bill you
know Americans elected the one man they
believe to do it a complete outsider
someone is beholding to no one what's
them from Ed Trump's team said that this
was all a big coincidence they didn't
mean to tell people through Jeanine
Pirro that Paul Ryan should be fired
should Paul Ryan stepped down no I don't
see why Paul Ryan should step down I
just think that he shouldn't push crappy
legislation in the future hey John
Boehner should have stepped down because
John Boehner actually wanted to
negotiate with Democrats to ram through
things if Paul Ryan starts to do that if
Paul Ryan follows the pattern here I
think that it's going to be a serious
problem previous came out he said that
the tweet about Ryan was coincidental
well first of all I
we'll go on record we do love judge
Jeanine and so does the president I I
think it was more coincidental Chris
come on I did not talk to the president
about the tweet I'm just telling you the
truth but there was no pre-planning here
at the president you visited president
why would he out say watch her and then
that's the first thing he loves judge
Jeanine and he want to do judge jeanine
a favor so don't want Paul Ryan to step
down at all he does them okay we can
stop it there of course Ryan's previous
is going to be saying that i'd be more
assured it's deven and we're saying that
cuz you've been actually hates Paul Ryan
whereas ranch grievances from Wisconsin
and his close friends with Paul Ryan
well I want to get to the house freedom
caucus and Trump attacking them in just
one second but first I want to say thank
you to one of our new sponsor stamped
com so if you hate postage machines if
you don't like waiting in line at the
post office and you would prefer to be
able you're sitting at home you want to
mail something you need to go over to
stamps.com right now if you go over to
stamps.com you get a four-week trial
with postage and digital scale the way
that this works is that you can get all
the postage that you need right from
your desk and stamps com you buy and
print official US postage for any letter
or package using your owner own computer
and printer you can print it out onto a
piece of paper and tape it onto you'd be
envelope the imprint sit down onto a
sticker you can print out directly onto
the envelope instead of you actually
having to go to the post office and wait
in line for a year and a day in order to
get the stamps you can instant and use
the they're weighing machine instead you
can do it online I've you stamps calm
for years actually to send important
letters and packages we are starting to
use it at the office as well right now
if you use my name's Shapiro for this
special offer you know four-week trial
includes postage in a digital scale so
you go to post you go to stamps.com
stamps com use my name is Shapiro for
the special offer again four-week trial
it includes postage as well as a digital
scale so you can waste up right at your
desk and chopped into there's a radio
microphone of top of the site and you
click on that and type in Shapiro so
that they know that we sent you that
stamps calm and you use again that promo
code Shapiro you get that four-week
trial including postage and a digital
scale which is actually a pretty solid
deal I mean how much mail are you going
to send for you and your business in
those four weeks a fair bit stamps.com
terrific service okay so the reason all
of this fighting infighting is broken
out is because president Trump refuses
to what the buck stop with him so again
this is one character flaw for Trump
hehe never just says okay my bad we
should have done this differently back
to the drawing board instead he issued
an ultimatum last Thursday in which he
said if we don't get a vote right now
we're not going to do anything on health
care because he didn't want to deal with
the problem and then he blamed the
freedom caucus so here is what Trump
tweeted about the freedom caucus he
treated Democrats are smiling in DC that
the freedom caucus with the help of club
for growth and heritage have saved
Planned Parenthood and Oh care this is
absolutely going and discussing the only
people who saved Planned Parenthood and
the funding for Obamacare and all the
rest of it are Donald Trump and Paul
Ryan and all the people who wanted to
push this crappy bill because the fact
is that this crap people would have
maintained all the central provisions of
Obamacare the only good thing it did was
restructure Medicare was actually really
a tree structure Medicaid making it into
a block grant instead of a need-based
program even that would have changed
over time because a new Congress would
come in from the Democratic side and
presumably reinstate it it wouldn't make
it a permanent change this is this idea
that it was the freedom caucus that
really sunk this club for growth and
heretics all those people supported him
okay I didn't vote for Trump okay I
didn't vote for Hillary either i remote
for either of them because when it came
to trump i was concerned that Trump
would basically just be governed like a
Democrat and and you know undercut a lot
of conservative values but that's not
for the freedom caucus or heritage or
Club for Growth all of them openly
supported president Trump and near his
trump slapping them in the face as hard
as he possibly can and let's just point
out when it comes to Planned Parenthood
when it comes to single-payer health
care there's only one person in this
entire equation who has come out in
favor of those things let's flash back
just a few short months ago when you get
rid of the lines it brings in
competition so instead of having one
insurance company taking care of New
York or Texas you'll have many they'll
compete and it'll be a beautiful thing
as far as planned parenthood is
concerned I'm pro-life I'm totally
against abortion having to do with
Planned Parenthood but millions and
millions of women cervical cancer breast
cancer are helped by Planned Parenthood
so you can say whatever you want but
they have millions of women going
through Planned Parenthood that are
helped greatly as far as a single payer
it works in canada it works incredibly
well in scotland it could have worked in
a different age which is the age you're
talking about here what i'd like to see
is a prior
it's system without the artificial lines
around every state get rid of the
artificial lines and you will have
yourself great plans and then we have to
stop it there okay the artificial lines
guess what wasn't in that bill oh yeah
the artificial lawn none of that was in
the bell and this is the only guy on the
stage he was talking about single parent
how wonderful it was in other countries
so before you start ripping on the
freedom caucus for saving Obamacare and
Planned Parenthood a couple notes number
one even this bill delayed funding for
Planned Parenthood by one year one year
that's it okay didn't abolish funding
for Planned Parenthood second of all
again Trump talking as though he cares
about this stuff is really galling the
people who truly cared about this stuff
weren't willing to enshrine all of this
bad policy okay so I'm gonna get to the
freedom caucus response and what is
obviously war on conservatives that has
now begun we may have seen the
high-water mark of Trump as a
conservative which I certainly hope
that's not the case I hope that he turns
back to the Conservatives but we'll talk
about all of that over its daily wire
com if you want to become a subscriber
it's eight dollars a month over at daily
wire.com if you want to come an annual
subscriber you get a free signed copy of
michael moses best-selling book reasons
to vote democrats a comprehensive guide
the most thorough guide to why to vote
democrat on available in print right now
daily wire.com you get that annual
subscription you get a free signed copy
of michael's brilliant book and if you
just want the the monthly subscription
to eight dollars a month you just want
to listen to us a little bit later then
go over to itunes or soundcloud download
the podcast and make sure the leave a
review over to itunes we really
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you